So finally we have got, Drew and Ross,
the rise of a whole new kind of party.
"Apartment Therapy" reports that people are getting together
for potluck and PowerPoint nights.
So this is when you invite your friends over
and everyone takes a turn
at giving a PowerPoint presentation
of their choice on any topic they're excited about.
Videos of these parties are showing up
on TikTok with creative presentations like,
my exes from most to least traumatizing,
or my friends as Beyonce songs.
So Ross, Drew, what would your PowerPoint topic be?
Well, I love this idea.
You had me at potluck
where you all just bring your favorite hot dish over.
But the PowerPoint threw me for a loop.
One, because I don't know how to do a PowerPoint.
Do you?
And number two, what would I do?
And I really thought long and hard about this.
And if you were coming, Drew, to mine,
I would put a PowerPoint together
of my favorite people from "90 day fiance".
And I would walk you through, this is Big Ed.
Big Ed's been through a lot.
Big Ed's number one.
Do you watch "90 days"?
Of course!
Oh, finally someone else
on this desk watches "90 day fiance".
You're missing out,
especially during these troubled times.
It's just what the doctor ordered.
I mean, I know I have a series to promote,
but really focus your attention on "90 day fiance".
I love it.
And June, what would your PowerPoint presentation be?
I have to say I'm with Ross.
Mine would be on just simply how to make a PowerPoint.
That's really what I'd have to drill down on
because I barely know how to update my computer.
I keep on seeing that little notice pop up and I say,
"X, not today."
(audience laugh)
I totally agree.
What would your PowerPoint be?
Mine?
Yeah, what would you do?
Every day, we do it right here at "Drew's news".
This is my daily PowerPoint of all things that are happening
in the world that are good, funny, irreverent, interesting,
and hopefully life affirming and shows, companies changing.
This is the kind of news I need.
So this is my PowerPoint presentation.
(audience clap)
June Diane Raphael, catch the final season
of "Grace and Frankie" on Netflix starting April 29th.
And I just love you.
I love you too.
Let's do this show together forever.
And we'll never get up.
Exactly, and I just love Kim Kardashian.
Listen, I've got Skims on right now.
I love Skims.
Oh my God, ready?
Hold on, Kim Kardashian.
They're so good!
Wow!
They're so good.
She's everywhere.
(audience clap)
That's how much I love Kim Kardashian.
She makes a good product.
I'm wearing you in this region.
I love her.
I love you.
I love Casey.
And I love your husband, Paul, who really set the tone
for how we could make a show
in a pandemic and bring people to this news desk.
And we have followed his model ever since.
And again, I dunno
if we can benefit financially from that, but.
Yeah, okay.
(upbeat music)